hello everybody let's talk about seven
books that I have read see me recently
mostly this year with kitties yes this
is beautiful little King Elfie that's
right and Bilbo is just over there I'll
go I'll go grab him and then so these
two
I gotta keep me company while I talk
about books you're right take a look
come closer Oh how'd you adorable
okay okay step step okay you're right
there we go isn't he so seven books one
two three four five six seven there I
have read Simmi recently put up a whole
lot of topics that people could could
have and just got a rescue something
from the cats mmm I'll talk see me
review about it and see me like just
kind of what I thought which is I guess
a review but it's not like gonna go
super deep into it I put a hop of bobbin
to topic is about what you'd want to see
me talk about and apparently this was
this was number one beating out just
very slim Lee what's it like to work at
a suicide hotline so the first book is
shared in boxes shadow of the Conqueror
and this book I'm gonna put to the side
there that's somewhat bitter it's
actually by a fellow youtuber as part of
that might be the reason part of the
reason that I wanted to read this book
is that I kind of know the guy I've
worked with him and he's really cool
it's a book about basically a tyrant who
he was a world horrible genocide 'el
tyrant and he he took over the world and
then he vanished and he wanted to repent
so that's his years on he wants to
repent from when he done he realizes oh
my gosh
I'm literally Hitler and he tries to
sort of reform himself and and no dog
jump across the table oh gosh they're
behind the camera I'm so sorry if you
can know they're chewing the microphone
stop jeez
so come here look get away from the
microphone come here yeah there we go
um it was good it was written for a very
particular kind of audience I think if
you're into Brandon Sanderson and it's
clearly directed about hard magic system
great world building very interesting
unique world sort of semi industrial
Victorian steampunk II kind of feel to
it with kind of a a high fantasy
undertone and it's definitely aimed at
that I I think that that's the big
strong points of the the story and yeah
I liked it had its flaws lot of flaws
that would be with with any kind of
first writer our first first novel of
any writer but also I think that there
was a lot of there was some service some
tension lost due to focus on the action
having to constantly segue way to talk
about the world building but you know
like that's that's almost part of the
style of that sub-genre of fantasy
anyways book to the rest of us just live
here by Patrick Ness so this is a young
adult novel which is kind of part of a
series of books that I'm reading sort of
to do with mental health and the the
common character in this series in this
book
has basically is simi sort of he gets
stuck in circles of panic and he does
things over and over obsessively so it
is it is sort of an OCD toilet the kind
of thing that's interesting to explore
the psychology behind that so they're
really interesting premise of the story
it says you know not everyone has to be
the chosen one and so throughout the
book there's this kind of narrative
going on behind the scenes where you
learn about these indie kids this other
group of kids who are supposedly saving
the world like in any other why a book
and these are about the kids who aren't
their main characters in that story
they're the side characters where
nothing interesting happens to them and
it's kind of interesting because the
honestly this book is a really peculiar
study and pacing and tension I nearly
rented it into it in my recent video on
pacing which is that this book has a
slow-paced first act second act and
third acts and it's it sort of just ins
it doesn't have like a real climax so
much I think that's sort of part of the
thematic idea behind the story but also
because you know I'm just gonna get some
more cats in the background let's just
let's just do that yeah I think that's
sort of part of the scheme of the story
that he was going for um but it was
still enjoyable because the sort of
tension and and the ideas that he was
trying to explore weren't necessarily
based and that kind of tension that you
would usually rely on so I enjoyed that
yep read that there was actually last
year that won this one I read actually
copy years ago a little just grabbed a
whole bunch of y-a books cuz I'm reading
why a right now reading a lot of young
adult contemporary fiction so this isn't
why I fantasy it's it's why a in the day
today times usually dealing with strong
personal issues and this were that
brings me to one of my favorite way
books paper don't know they're trying to
pull the Kurds down it's really adorable
do you want to see it
go on so let's move over here so we just
got we got more kitties in the
background so Paper Towns is my favorite
why a book because it's one of the few
books that actually I've read this years
ago I'm sorry it's not like that the
topic was just books you've read and I
mean I've read does it you're right come
here
okay I've read dozens of books and I
just sort of picked some but I'm in a
why a mood so I picked kind other ones
that I've written done it's one of the
only books where I sort of read it and
then I got to the end and I was like
holy crap that's taught me something
formatic Lee that's hit me hard because
the sort of something that happens that
he realizes at the end of the book one
of the things that Margo Roth Spiegelman
cost mouth for I'm like oh wow I have
done that and I really like that cuz you
sort of think about you you always hear
about how you've got to try and knock
your audience or your reader down with a
thematic message but it really very
rarely happens but this one did for me
this one did and it's it's written
really introspectively and the movie
doesn't capture it because the movie
just can't capture the nuance in why a
books cuz so much of it is inside the
head so much of it you know pages web
pages it's just thought and you can do a
monologue over the you know narrative
over the top of whatever is happening
but it doesn't work you can say a few
sentences and then the audience turns
out where the written of the book you
can read it pages and pages and there's
a really crucial scene halfway through
it freezing this mall and you get the
scene where he's in the mall in the film
but it just falls flat because you don't
get all of the introspective stuff
because you can't yeah so here's another
book which is my heart and other black
holes by Jasmine Walker now this is a
story about a cat called Iselle and
Roman which is it it's a mental health
book as well I read a lot of them try to
get my hands on there just to keep
reading about stuff that I
what are you doing what they're trying
to play foosball currently no stop look
I'm trying to film you okay and
basically these these two characters
have drawn themselves into a suicide
pact together and throughout the course
of the book they both or either of them
I'm not gonna spoil which kind of deal
with those thoughts and their feelings
for one another so it does it's not a
great like it's not the quintessential
this is a great wire but can only do
health not at all
I I have a lot of thoughts on how people
often pair mental health and romance and
like where the romance can cure it or
make it better and it's like on the one
hand yeah loving someone and having
things to live for is a really good
thing that plays into people stopping
having those thoughts but on the other
hand love is not a magic bullet it's
love is not a pill that gets you out of
it you know it's it's a lot harder and
people who are in love you know and are
suicidal it can be really hard on them
and it can be really hard on their
partners and I don't see a lot of books
deal with that which I would really like
to see I would really like to see more
of and the book that I'm writing is in a
sense kind of a response to a lot of
these tropes but won't go into that
so do I recommend it I recommend it in
the sense that like just read it if
you're looking to get a good spread of
like why a stuff that deals in mental
health it's an interesting example but
yeah this is consider fleebus and
apologize for the bookmarks in there
oh this is consider fleebus by Iain
Banks it's the first in a series the
culture series and it's a sci-fi double
it's a hard sci-fi novel from like the
80s
or the 90s you figure it out when were
you published 1989 1988 now first
published in 1987 yes so this is all
this is a while ago really interesting
it's really nicely written but honestly
I don't find the premise that compelling
I find it a bit slow and a bit side
Cristi you sort of get there and you've
got a problem and you solve it and you
can get somewhere else but ultimately it
doesn't add up too much but apparently
got recommended to me by a friend that
it is one of the best series he's ever
read and this is only the first in the
series which is apparently a strange one
to start off with all of it as Russian
from the perspective of another
civilization in the series otherwise so
yeah I don't take take take my thoughts
with a grain of salt but I did enjoy
didn't do the writing style but the
world didn't grab me as much as it as I
felt it could yeah so the one that I'm
reading at the moment though is a why a
contemporary book called it's kind of a
funny story which I referenced in my
recent on writing pacing video and I'm
only a little bit into it I'm only like
100 pages about that much and I like how
it's depicting one particular thing so
far really interestingly and that is
it's practically about this boy who's
very depressed and there's this
interesting scene where he can't eat he
he he fights it really hard to eat and
come here look and his mum and parents
like put together this whole dinner to
make him happy just like get him to eat
you know like it's your favorite food
it's got lots of stuff and we tried our
best we all got together and then he
can't eat it and he has to spew it up
and the way that he
that need Vizzini explores kind of the
feelings of guilt around not being able
to eat and other people go into the
efforts it's a really nice exploitation
of that abstraction from you know like
wanting to be able to eat but not being
able to eat and the guilt that comes out
of that because people who don't have
that find it really hard to understand
you know like it's good food it's we put
a lot of effort you even wanted to
what's the problem
you know like and if they wanted to then
the problem must be with me and that's
sort of unhealthy oh you're ruining my
books people that unhealthy kind of
toxicity that sort of comes out of it
it's really hard on all the parties and
I really like the exploration and yes
I'm only a little bit into that I don't
know where it goes after that apparently
haven't even met one of the main
characters yet and the last book here is
Eleanor & Park which is by Rainbow
Rowell which I refuse to believe is a
real name
it's got to be something else and
Eleanor parks good yeah yes it's good it
was fine fine do you know what hugs fine
I want hugs you always been to one hugs
Elfi you always want cuddles why do you
no one cuddles today they're being too
playful they've just been bored like all
the time and it's actually been a while
since I've read this thank you so much
that I can can't even really remember
much to what happens basically two kids
fall in love it and they sort of changed
one another it's one of those typical
stories it was good nothing spectacular
but you know Eleanor has a hard life in
one way Park has a hard life in another
way they learned from one another and it
was simple sweet and while it's not the
best way a book I've ever read it might
be for for particular kind of person who
enjoys those types of stories so
altogether though
the books that I've read say me recently
I've read all the ones as well but I
sort of couldn't find them I'll just
quickly grabbing them when I came all
the way to my parents house to film this
with the kittens which by the way do you
want to see more kittens of course you
want to see more kittens come here
God yeah there we go
well they adorable
oh hello your chlorine me now and you
want hugs at last
hmm no okay fine just go up there
there we go by the way
that's all for me that's the vlog for
this week in a single take just sit back
and do them in the meantime stay nerdy
and no hang on
in the meantime yeah I'll get them both
because they need to say goodbye to
their subjects okay in the meantime stay
nerdy and King Elfie and King Bilbo
we'll see you in the future